[Music]
on this Saturday night's breaking news a
Halloween Stampede in Seoul
dozens kills in a crowd crushed during
weekend festivities
human chain for Iran
the canada-wide protest and the regime's
toughest warning yet
the bitterly fought Brazilian election
and the fate of the Amazon rainforest
and Master of Disguise a former spy's
new Mission bringing people out of
hiding
global national with Fara Nasser
good evening to you thanks so much for
joining us we're going to begin tonight
with the breaking news out of South
Korea where we know at least 146 people
are dead and another 150 are injured
after being trapped and crushed in an
apparent crowd surge during Halloween
celebrations in Seoul
oh my God oh my God
local media reports there were as many
as a hundred thousand people in the
narrow streets of the city's
Entertainment District for Saturday
night Halloween festivities Witnesses
say people were jammed together and that
they couldn't breathe and they were
crushed after the crowd began pushing
forward in an alley dozens of bodies
were placed on the streets under blue
sheets before being taken to a nearby
gym to be identified many of the victims
were in their 20s more than 800
emergency responders have been deployed
from across the country and the death
toll is sadly expected to rise as many
of the injured are currently in critical
condition
thousands of Canadians lined up in
cities across our country joining a
global human chain protest to support
the people of Iran a brutal Crackdown on
widespread protests continues within the
country with the Revolutionary guard
stepping up warnings to what it calls
rioters here today prime minister Justin
Trudeau led the protest in Ottawa and
had harsh words for Iran's Islamic
regime Den Specter reports
[Music]
prime minister Justin Trudeau joins
hundreds of protesters in Ottawa many of
them Iranian Canadians as they deliver a
clear message
they gathered to loudly denounce the
Iranian regime and offer support to
demonstrators who have been risking
their lives to take to the streets of
Iran for over 40 days now galvanized by
the death of 22 year old Masa amini who
died in the custody of the so-called
morality police after being arrested for
not wearing her hijab correctly at least
270 people have been killed and 14 000
arrested according to Human Rights
activists this is a revolution 25 year
old niaesh zaifi left Iran in 2019 to
study in Canada she said back in her
home country she had been arrested three
times just for the way she was dressed
it's not normal
but yeah we've all been through it and
it's very dehumanizing and derogatory
many in Ottawa holding signs displaying
the names and photos of demonstrators
killed by authorities in recent weeks
this woman tied up to symbolize the
oppression in Iran I'm doing this makeup
to show that we're gonna We're Not Gonna
shut up and my people are gonna fight to
get their freedom support for the
Iranian protesters could be seen from
coast to coast in Vancouver a human
chain marched across the Lionsgate
bridge in Toronto thousands line Young
Street demonstrators also marched in
Halifax all part of a global movement in
dozens of cities around the world the
Iranian people deserve more than
being killed on the streets as if their
lives don't matter but their lives do
matter the coordinated action came as
the Iranian revolutionary guard told
demonstrators in Iran this would be the
last day of protests it's not going to
be the last day of course it's going to
be the last day if the government today
goes
so that would be the last day of protest
enough enough for the brutality enough
of the repression crowds in Ottawa
cheered as the Prime Minister denounced
the regime's human rights abuses and its
attack on flight PS 752 in 2020 killing
dozens of Canadians those people people
responsible now will never be forgotten
will never be allowed into Canada
Trudeau praised the Iranian Canadian
Community saying in adds to the vibrancy
of Canada inspector Global News Ottawa
the man charged with attempting to kill
U.S House speaker Nancy Pelosi's husband
appears to have made racist and often
rambling posts online including some
that question the results of the 2020
election
the man also has a Canadian connection
he grew up in Powell River BC before
moving to San Francisco two decades ago
Jennifer Johnson reports
82-year-old Paul Pelosi remains
hospitalized after surgery repairing a
skull fracture and other injuries
Mr Pelosi managed to call 9-1-1 sending
officers to their San Francisco home
which was not under guard because the
house speaker was in Washington officers
witnessed the violent attack the suspect
42-year-old David depap used a hammer to
repeatedly strike Paul Pelosi her
officers immediately tackled the suspect
disarmed him took him into custody to
Pap's stepfather in British Columbia
says he hasn't seen him in almost 20
years but as a child was quiet and never
violent police say depap intended to tie
Paul Pelosi up and wait for Nancy Pelosi
to come home
since the January 6 riot at the Capitol
threats and attacks have dramatically
increased against American elected
officials in the first three months of
2022 the U.S Capitol Police threat
assessment team opened over 1800 cases
police say depab was often online
repeating former president Donald
Trump's baseless claims the 2020
election was stolen but also conspiracy
theories of democratic officials running
child sex Rings this was not a random
act this was intentional
in July members of Congress were given
ten thousand dollars each to upgrade
security at their homes with just over a
week till the midterm elections U.S
President Joe Biden is calling for an
end to the threats every person of good
conscience
needs to clearly and unambiguously
stand up against the violence in our
politics regardless what your politics
are the house Speaker who had a weekend
booked campaigning for midterm
candidates is now home in San Francisco
her wealthy neighborhood shaken by the
attack I really don't know what to say
because it's just so sad and frustrating
Capitol Police and the FBI have joined
the investigation house Speaker Pelosi
is often the target of credible threats
she is given protective security detail
but her husband is not
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
a new report by the veterans Ombudsman
backs up what veterans have been saying
for some time that they are struggling
to access disability benefits according
to the report vets wait on average 43
weeks for decisions regarding their
claims now all this is happening is
calls grow from employees at Veterans
Affairs Canada for the minister of
Veterans Affairs to resign our Mercedes
Stevenson joins us now with more on this
from Ottawa Mercedes
Farah Canadian veterans have put their
lives and limbs on the line for this
country and Advocates say many are in
crisis facing broken promises and
feeling forgotten by the country the
frustration and concerns about neglect
aren't coming out of the blue either
veterans are supposed to wait about 16
weeks on average to have their
disability benefits assessed for
injuries from their service like PTSD
and traumatic brain injuries but this
week the veterans Ombudsman said
veterans are waiting on average 43 weeks
that's almost 10 months and the wait is
having an impact veterans are waiting
they're struggling and they're getting
further and further behind and it's
having a greater impact on their mental
health when a veteran feels like they're
a burden on their family the situation
is getting worse according to the panel
we convened on the west block this week
and they say not enough is being done to
fix it more veterans have died by
Suicide than Canadian soldiers were
killed in the entirety of the Afghan war
and that statistic was a contributing
factor in the feelings of anger and
frustration among some veterans when
Global News reported that one Canadian
veteran was told he could pursue medical
assistance in dying as an alternative to
treatment by a vac employee vac isn't
allowed to offer made and the minister
and Department have both insisted that
this is a one-off but still under
investigation when they appeared at
committee hearings called into the issue
but the growing disapproval Over The
Minister's performance has led the union
that represents vac employees to call
for The Minister's resignation this week
and they're not the only ones the bar
wasn't set very high with his
predecessors and he seems to be not even
be able to make that so I think you know
with the workers calling for his
resignation I think it's it's as well
warranted and frankly as a member as
advisory committee I would I would
suggest the same so you think the
minister should resign Bruce 100 yes
this always needs to be a minister who's
very capable very Hands-On and
action-oriented and Mr McCauley is not
like that so he's got either step up or
step out we'll have more on Veterans in
crisis and check in with ER doctors
about the Staggering wait times in
emergency rooms across Canada Farah
thank you Mercedes and you can see the
full veterans panel discussion on the
west block that's tomorrow right here on
global
reaction has been pouring in across the
country after BC announced an overhaul
to its child welfare program in order to
give First Nations control over their
children
because despite being a small fraction
of the population in British Columbia
indigenous children make up the majority
of kids in foster care now this move is
happening as the federal government
reckons with compensating families for
policies found to be discriminatory meet
the garcha takes a deeper look
uh-huh
BC is poised to become the first
province in Canada to legally recognize
the right of indigenous communities to
provide their own child welfare systems
our children have an inherent right to
know who they are where they come from
what they belong to the current
legislation in The Province does not
allow the BC government to hand over
cases of children entering or already in
care to an indigenous government the
proposed amendments include new
information sharing and consent
agreements bringing BC in line with
similar Federal legislation bill c-92
which came into force in 2020. this day
Heralds the achievement of the goals
pursued for many years by successive
Chiefs and councils the news has been
acclaimed by Advocates as a positive
step forward with the Hope other
provinces will follow suit in December
we're going to the Supreme Court because
Quebec challenged c92 or the ability for
us to have to have our own laws and
jurisdiction so throughout there's
definitely uh you know there's from one
extreme to the other Advocate Mary tigi
has also been involved in negotiations
at the heart of a second major
announcement this week the Canadian
Human Rights tribunal rejecting ottawa's
offer to compensate indigenous Children
and Families harmed by the
discriminatory on Reserve System they
rejected it because many of the victims
that would be otherwise entitled to
compensation were going to be left out
and that just did not fit well with us
TG says the 20 billion dollar cap for
compensation a key part of the larger 40
billion dollar deal described as
historic by the feds would leave out an
estimated 15 000 victims covered by The
Landmark ruling and points to a solution
tribunal States is that what they are
saying is that 20 billion that's already
earmarked for compensation be placed in
a trust and the interest from that 20
billion would be utilized to compensate
other victims but that would hinge on
having all sides agree the Assembly of
First Nations lead negotiator called the
rejection deeply frustrating and sad
Ashley Bach who says she was taken from
her family shortly after birth is
worried for all those who expected to
receive compensation early in the new
year I want them to say that to the
youth from Nan territory um who tried to
kill herself like on the side of the
road in my hands because she aged out
and was homeless and had no money and
honestly to me it sounded like she
didn't have any hope for the future
which are things that the compensation
will help to alleviate box says no
funding amount will ever be perfect and
delays are unacceptable and suddenly
these other concerns are being pulled
out of nowhere in order to um in order
to delay it a plea highlighting the
urgency Behind These fundamental changes
aimed at helping to reduce the
over-representation of indigenous
children in care often on the brink of
poverty when they age out of it
Global News Burnaby BC
coming up it's the final push for two
populist heavyweights ahead of Brazil's
election tomorrow why Brazilian
democracy in the fit at the Amazon
rainforest are both on the ballot
one of the biggest democracies in the
world picks a new president tomorrow
Brazilians will cast their ballots in a
runoff election that at this point is
too close to call according to experts
and it has been a very bitter campaign
including a testy final debate but as
Mike Armstrong explains the election is
not just about which populist candidate
is going to be president but the future
of the planet with the Amazon rainforest
at stake
there has been nothing out of bounds in
this campaign from the incumbent side
jira bolsonaro there have been
accusations his opponent is supported by
satanists and from The Challengers
campaign Lula there have been
accusations bolsonaro considered
cannibalism to get votes
but the runoff campaign wrapping up
polls put Lula in the lead but barely
but it is evil
political scientist Carlos Pereira calls
the election entirely unpredictable he
says Lula's ahead but that it's
impossible to say who'll win
what makes this one so hard to call may
have a lot to do with bolsonaro's pitch
to voters he's borrowed from the Donald
Trump populism Playbook bolsonaro pushes
distrust in state institutions
everything from the courts to the Board
of Elections bolsters have trouble
pegging his support because his
supporters distrust pollsters
first round vote earlier this month
bolsonaro finished in second with 42.2
percent that was higher than expected
and came despite mismanagement of the
pandemic the country had close to 700
000 deaths
and growing poverty oh sentiment there
is a feeling among people their lives
are economically worse off he says and
we recognize that
now the front runner is a former
president Luis enacio Lula de Silva is
known as Lula and ran the country from
2003 to 2010 when he left power he had
an approval rating close to 90 percent
but his reputation took a hit when his
hand-picked successor ended up in a
recession and a corruption Scandal
erupted Lula himself was arrested and
spent more than 500 days in jail over a
bribery conviction that was eventually
overturned in a country where so many
already distrust politicians Lula's past
scandals are seen by many as just the
sort of thing they all do Brazil's
economy grew under Lula and he's
pitching himself as the person to do it
again
calls himself the candidate with the
experience to rebuild the country
so there are important issues that
divide the two candidates bolsonaro
loosened gun control laws in recent
years lulas talked about tightening them
and they differ on climate change as
well Lula has promised to fight
deforestation in the Amazon something
that is surged under bolsonaro he says
enough of it's protected already well
the future of the world's largest
rainforest is on the ballot Sunday it
just may not be a top concern in a
country where poverty is a growing
problem
Mike Armstrong Global News
[Music]
the color of your skin
getting proper timely Health Care in
Canada is tough enough but if you're
black there is another complication to
be considered systemic bias and racism
that's been plaguing the system for
decades in hopes of sparking change and
addressing the role it plays this week
Canada's foremost medical journal
released the first edition of its
two-part anti-black racism series a
compilation of Articles and research by
black authors as Jamie Morocco reports
experts say it's a small step toward
more Equitable care
when breast cancer patient Michelle odoy
made the decision to have a double
mastectomy she expressed some concerns
specific to the color of her skin no
doctor she says could answer her
questions I really felt like my issues
didn't matter and I didn't feel
confident in making a decision about a
life-changing surgery because I didn't
see myself represented stories like
odwase play out every day in Canada's
Health Care System part of the problem
experts say is a lack of education and
understanding due to minimal research
and data published by black Educators
and clinicians and in Canada the impacts
become even more difficult to measure
because Registries don't routinely
collect race data despite this being the
norm in the U.S and UK it becomes unsafe
Healthcare that we are more likely to
experience compared to our white
counterparts in 2020 Dr Oni norm and Dr
Omi Sharay Dryden asked the prominent
Canadian Medical Association journal to
set aside space to dive into the issues
bypoc patients face unique to Canadian
Health Care the stereotypes lead to
exacerbating our overall health care
lead to a delay in seeking Health
interventions and can lead to earlier
death and poorer outcomes
two years later the first articles show
black patients face more barriers when
accessing primary care physicians and
screening programs and reveal mortality
from certain cancers are higher in Black
patients than white the numbers don't
tell you everything you have to actually
have the numbers and carry enough about
those folks to mobilize resources or to
have public accountability for change oh
Dwayne who was initially told she had
early stage breast cancer pushed for
more tests only to be re-diagnosed with
stage four now she advocates for equity
for other cancer patients it has to move
Beyond symbolic posturing or
performative measures it has to be
systemic change
change that could mean the difference
between life and death Jamie moroccer
Global News
[Music]
next Undercover Mission how a former CIA
agent is helping people face the world
again
there is a hidden world of people who
live with physical disfigurements could
be a result of a genetic abnormality or
maybe a traumatic event and for these
people just going outside the house can
be daunting
but one man has made it his mission to
help them pass through life unnoticed
this week for the new reality Jackson
prosco introduces us to a former spy
with a remarkable Talent Jackson
inside this pretty unassuming office
complex in Virginia something remarkable
is happening it's where ultra realistic
works of art take shape that have the
power to change human lives Robert
Barron is a former CIA disguise expert
who turned his talent for making
incredible disguises into a skill that
has helped hundreds of people he makes
prosthetics for people who have been
disfigured by birth defect or trauma
from noses to full face masks perhaps
even more remarkable than his work is
the story of how he perfected the art of
helping people hide in plain sight
during his decades spent working at the
CIA
the disguises had to pass the closest
scrutiny you know like
six to 12 inches
and if they didn't then their life would
be in Jeopardy that they could put it on
in three seconds three seconds and take
it off in three seconds a complete face
yes absolutely that sounds like
something out of Mission Impossible
how about Mission possible
[Laughter]
today patients come from around the
world for a chance to sit in Robert's
chair we'll take you along through their
remarkable Journey on the new reality
back to you
thanks Jackson you can catch Jackson's
full story on Robert Barron on the new
reality tonight at 7 right here on
global and that is global national for
this Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser on
behalf of our whole team here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your Saturday evening with us tonight's
your Canada is Rocky Lake in Manitoba
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
foreign